so today I want to talk to you about
some machine learning algorithms there
are really not much discussed for
example we talk a lot about how to work
with
text for example right so for example if
I have some text and I want to predict
maybe the next word or something and
those are large language models for
example that we see a lot out there
maybe maybe I'm interested in comparing
images right for example let's say this
is a dog this is my very good
impersonation for dog and this is let's
say a cat
and then I want to predict
is this new image a dog or a cat
um we also have a lot of algorithms that
work with tabular data so like in a
table and I want to find out whether
this person maybe is eligible for a loan
but
same thing but with graphs
so here are two graphs they will show to
you
I have graph G1 and graph G2 this graph
has six nodes so this color blobs are
called nodes and the connections between
them are called edges
in this particular graph the nodes have
color so they can be red or blue and
there are six notes with one two three
four five six edges as well and we have
a second graph which kind of looks maybe
similar it also has six notes with the
difference that I have three blues here
rather than two and the connections here
are a bit different they kind of look
like molecule maps are the colors
important the differences and colors
that's awesome comments uh I was gonna
exactly discuss why do we do these
things and molecules are the best
example so maybe if you have something
that looks like a molecule like a carbon
connected to an oxygen that's connected
to a hydrogen and this keeps going I'm
not a chemist so I don't know how this
is gonna go but
um I could think that maybe I would
represent a carbon with a red blob and
an oxygen with a blue one for the
chemists out there this is probably not
real molecule but we don't care but you
could
absolutely model molecules not graphs
you could model other things you could
model friendship networks in which
colors maybe represent people's
preferences about a certain topic
um
or something that identifies them in
some way so these are obviously graphs
in a kind of true sense that way with
nodes and edges they're not we're not
looking at plots here not plots and
that's the first important distinction
that we should but could you do plants
like this as well or is that diff is
that different
for what we're going to see today
plots cannot be analyzed with the same
algorithms
what we're going to look today are very
specific to graphs in that sense of
nodes and edges network is a way to
describe them a network is a way that
you maybe differ the growth these
actually could be parts of a cloud or
something couldn't they it could
actually could be they could be
knowledge graphs that I know you
discussed in the channel before they
could be anything that you can represent
with connections maybe it's a natural
question that we have maybe I have a
third graph
that I'm going to draw here
um
maybe this third graph looks something
like
this
right
so here I have a third graph I'm calling
it very creatively G3 and
you can see it's a bit different from G1
and G2 it also has
unlike the other ones it has one two
three four five six seven notes instead
of six again Sean maybe you can tell me
reasons why G3 should be more similar to
G1 and maybe reasons that it should be
more similar to G2 so obviously I'm
looking there upside down but actually
it probably shouldn't matter actually
she loves it very good
um but looking at you know the the G1 to
G2 you've got that kind of triangle at
your the top from where you are
um but then it feels like G1 to me
because it's just maybe an extension
taking those two Blues to be three and
it feels more like that and to me than
G2 and and there is this kind of yeah
that kind of a kind of things coming out
of it which here we have too but with an
extra one so maybe kind of these parts
is sort of similar on the other hand
this part is very similar to this one it
seems oh yeah the other way around of
course yeah but it's upside down but
again maybe we don't care about this of
course these are toy examples right
these are like not realistic examples
but maybe in real life These are
molecules again coming back to the
example and maybe this G1 belongs to a
big group of molecules that somehow are
good they are drug that solves your
problem they are active or something and
these are not good or inactive
you you may want to come up with a new
one and say should this belong to group
one or group two so before actually
going there and like doing the
synthesization of them could I maybe
have models that will tell me kind of
looks more like this blocks like this so
today we're going to see two very very
very simple models
that nonetheless are going to give us
conflicting answers and the reason why
they give conflicting answers is to
highlight the fact that working with
graphs is really hard and we're not
never expected to have one final only
way of doing things
because there are presumably all sorts
of different ways of saying they're
similar you know how many edges what
different colors how many you know how
do you measure it I suppose is the
question isn't it and I've you've
touched on something that's quite uh
profound so if you have two vectors and
maybe two vectors like this and they
have numbers like there may be one two
five and seven and the other one is one
two
four and seven you want to know if they
are the same it's very easy you just
walk from the beginning of the vector
comparing the entries if they are the
same keep going if they are different
you know the vectors are different and
you are done that can be done in linear
time for those of you who like
complexity
um of algorithms graphs not that easy
the graph isomorphism problem is not
known to be solvable in that quick way
so
the whole point is that we can't even
tell if graphs are the same so let alone
the degree of similarity that they have
that's exactly what we're going to
calculate degree of similarity but it's
not an unique answer
and maybe there's one takeaway of this
whole video is that when we do such
similarities in comparison between
graphs we throw information away
what we throw away and what we keep is
the magic so if you're applying this to
some sort of application specific some
specific application you may want to
discard some information you may want to
keep some other information and that's
the important choice that you would have
to make we start with an algorithm
called
vertex histogram
you probably remember histograms from
maybe when you studied statistics so if
I would look at G1 for example and I
want to maybe count so histograms
immediately here counting the number of
occurrences of a given color labeled in
that case so for G1 I'll have two blue
ones and one two three four four red
ones so this is my histogram for the
first graph I will not draw histograms
as plots like this I'm just going to
draw vectors so that's going to be
quicker I think so I'm just gonna get
booze oh God okay
um
threads and we're just going to
calculate I'm going to call them VH
prefer text histogram in this case of G1
so this is going to be a vector that has
two Blues
and forwards
and then vertex the circum of G2
what happens well I have three blues
here and three Reds so this is going to
be a three comma three
so you see what I'm doing I'm suddenly
creating a vector that sort of
represents the graphs now you're
probably thinking there are many things
that we're discarting with this that
we're gonna analyze later okay so at
this point you could get this vectors
put it to a nice Cartesian plane place
them there and do your favorite favorite
algorithm of course this is a toy
example but imagine that you have
hundreds and hundreds of those points
you could use nearest neighbor
classifier you could use anything that
you want we are going to use something
called kernel methods we're not going to
get into the details of the kernel
methods but we're going to go just see
one example of how they work so
if I want to use the kernel method
I will take the inner product between
three and one and three and two because
I want to compare three right so I at
this point I don't want to compare one
with two I just want to compare three
with both of them so
we're gonna go through step by step
so if I do
the inner product is going to be two
comma four
if you have not done inner products or
dot products before you can just it's
just a sort of a multiplication of
vectors in such a way that you multiply
entry by entry and add
them together so in this case I do two
times four which gives me eight
plus four times three and that's 12 so
this would be eight plus twelve
and that gives me 20. if I do the same
thing with G2 now and G3 I'm going to
get we don't have to write it down we
can just look in here it's going to be 4
times 3 12 plus 3 times 3 that's 9 which
gives us twenty one right inner products
are a good measure of similarity between
two things two vectors for the purpose
of this particular part of the algorithm
we can conclude that T3 is more similar
to 2 because 21 is more than 20 then 2g1
you're probably thinking many many
things at this point because you'll be
like
um well I can't I can come up with so
many examples of things that shouldn't
be similar but give me a high number
here and that's absolutely true I mean I
will give you many
um I if you if you just have one vector
that has huge numbers and the other one
has low numbers
this product is going to be high
um if
um
maybe maybe higher than the comparing it
with itself which should be the utmost
similarity but nonetheless
inner products are understood this
measure of similarity
and especially because we are going to
use algorithms such as svms support
Vector machines
in which inner products play a very
Central role
and comparing and creating the
boundaries between the classes and
everything
um
if you are really bothered with the fact
that these numbers are
very high or that you could get
similarity that's much higher than you
would like otherwise with
um
outlier numbers here you can always
normalize your vectors now it depends on
your application maybe normalizing does
not make sense maybe normalizing does
make sense so again it really depends on
the particular
algorithm you're using
okay Sean there is a there is a central
piece missing in whatever I've done here
it's this yeah Jesus name exactly and
and what they're connected to not not
just how many there are but where they
are and all of that sort of stuff
awesome actually not even how many they
are at this point we are completely
ignoring we're not taking into account
edges
at all
um nonetheless this is a very simple
example that I like doing because it
gives us a flavor of what's going on
there is one thing that may be bothering
you does it mean that if you put this in
a support Vector machine algorithm the
fact that 21 is higher than 20 would
automatically be the case that G3 is
classified as the same group as the G2
not necessarily support Vector machines
work with a lot of different parameters
and there are biased bias terms and and
all all sorts of other parameters and
factors that should be taken into
account but nonetheless
in the measure of similarity still works
so the higher the number the more
similar it's sort of the opposite as
distance where the higher the number the
more different
now we're gonna get edges into the whole
thing and see what happens this is
called vice versa Lehmann algorithms
in this case we're going to do the graph
kernel version of them they show up in
other parts of graph Theory
what we're going to do
and the basis of what we're doing now is
the following look at this for example
this red node and this other red note
they are similar because they're both
red
but they
are also similar in the sense that they
have only one neighbor
that happens to be blue so they are not
only the same color but their neighbors
have the same color unlike for example
this one and this one so the top one
here is red but actually neighbors are
red in a blue whereas this is red and
neighbors are blue
so for the purpose of this algorithm now
we're going to say that these two things
are the same but these two things are
not the same anymore because their
neighborhoods are different we're going
to analyze all the patterns that we see
in this particular graph I'm now writing
WL
and I'm putting a number one
you may guess y1 is in here at this
point but we're going to discuss later
is that for one neighbor
it's not from one neighbor I'm gonna
give you a spoiler it's
um I'm only looking at immediate
Neighbors
so I'm looking only at neighbors with
distance one distance one exactly so
you're gonna guess that wl2 is going to
somehow look at neighbors of neighbors
so the first pattern that I'm gonna
analyze is the one we just discussed so
it's a red
comma and I'm adding a comma here to
clarify that the first red is the actual
nodes label and what comes after The
Comma is the color of the neighbors
because it could have more than one so
it's red comma blue
again
we're gonna do a histogram again but
with the new patterns so
how many in the first graph have that
behavior so this one is a red with a
blue one this one is also red with a
blue neighbor but the other two are not
the same so there are two
other only have one red yeah okay take
out one red with a blue neighbor okay
but if you go to Second graph it seems
that there is only one here right this
one
is it red with a blue neighbor and the
other Reds they have Reds as neighbors
so they shouldn't be the same pattern so
we have a one here now for G3 I have
three actually right because I have this
one this one and this one terabytes with
blue neighbors so it's going to be a
long Vector longer than just two because
now all the intricacies are being taken
into account
um and so not to get lost because this
can be confusing I'm gonna tick all the
nodes that I've already processed in a
way
if you actually want to implement this
uh there is martaways of doing it you
use hash functions and you're going to
use all sorts of things so let's get
this thing done and then let's see
what's happening
[Music]
at this point we've ticked all the nodes
in the first graph
so we know that the rest of this feature
Vector here has will have a bunch of
zeros in the first line because there is
no more patterns to pick up
also you probably realize that two plus
two plus two is equal to 6 and as it
should be because as each node will
contribute to one tick in here and the
second one will also have to add up to
six and the last one will have taught up
to seven because I have seven notes
[Music]
right
we seem to have
some feature vectors going on you can
see there are a bunch more zeros now
because there are many patterns that we
only find in one or two of the grams
and if you have done machine learning at
this point you probably realize that
something that is potentially starting
to happen here is called overfitting as
we get more and more details on the
start of type of patterns we get
it could be that we are too focused on
the very very very fine details of our
training data and we fail to generalize
so when we see something new everything
is different so how much of this fine
graining you do depends on again the
application you want and depends on
again on
things that you want to do you may think
that for example this will never be used
the vertex histogram one because it
disregards all the edges right so why
would we use it nonetheless it can be a
baseline for your model let's go back to
here and finalize our calculation so
we're taking the inner or dot products
between these two things so what happens
if I do W L1 of G1 with
wl1 of G3
I'm not going to rewrite the whole
vectors down we can just look here and
see what's going to happen so this first
product is going to be six
but it so happens that every other
product is going to be zero because two
times zero zero zero and then 1.0 and 0
and 0 and 0. so the inner product
so the similarity using this algorithm
in this case is six I should mention at
this point
many implementations don't have just
this Vector here but appends some
concatenates the first one the vertex
histogram at the beginning so I would
have something like 2 comma four comma
the rest and in that case I would not
get a six I would get 20 plus six but
for this example let's just stick with
with the second half and finally I can
do
wl1 of G2 and compare with
G3
and then I get 1 times 3 which is 3 then
once with a zero and that's zero again
and there's a one here and there's also
another one here so I get
three plus one plus one which is five
again this is a measure of similarity
that has a lot of caveats in it it's not
exactly a final say of everything but
it's just an example to see how in this
case G3 seems more similar to G1 whereas
before it would be more similar to G2
because it was a 21 versus 20 and in
this case we have a five versus six or
six four the first one but obviously
there's only one in it for both those
examples isn't it I mean they're very
similar they're just all very similar
right they are it's just one and has a
very tiny difference again doesn't mean
your support Vector machine algorithm is
going to do it
um we have not discussed exactly how
these numbers go into your algorithm uh
for those of you who know kernel trick
it has to do with that it has this idea
that you do not need necessarily to know
the future vectors in order to do your
prediction in real life
um you would not have only three graphs
you would have many many more and you
have you will train in many more
um of them and you test in some others
so this is just a toy example
if you actually implement this as svms I
do think uh for the first one this is
going to be classified as
um closer to to G2 but again
there are bias terms involved and the
number is not a predictive necessarily
of what's going to happen but just to
get a feel of how these things are
working the kernel Matrix that's going
to come out of this for wl1 which we're
not going to go into detail is going to
be something like this that if I compare
graph 2 with graph 3 which is this one I
get a five so I also get a five here and
I get a six if I compare three with two
and I can fill these with other numbers
so the magic happens because in support
Vector machines for example you can just
put this Matrix into the algorithm and
get a predictions so you don't
necessarily need to know this thing
there are many graph kernel algorithms
that actually don't ever do this because
maybe those are infinitely long vectors
but nonetheless you can get a number and
this number is going to be what you're
going to use there's one last thing you
may be wondering at this point
you may say well okay look at these two
red nodes again
they are both red they're similar they
both have a blue neighbor so they're
even more similar but more than that
their blue neighbor so happens to have
one red and one blue neighbor so
they're similar if I go up to distance
two if you want so the neighbors of the
neighbors happen to be the same unlike
these two although they are both red and
both have a blue neighbor the neighbors
of the blue neighbors are different
because this one has a blue neighbor
with a bunch of neighbors and this one
has a blue neighborhood with just two
neighbors so we can keep going and we
can keep going forever
so I could just create wl2 in which case
wl2 would have patterns that would look
a bit different
and you at this point you may be
wondering I am going to get lost right
where do I stop like neighbors of name
like how do I even write it down okay so
that that I pre I pre-drawn this because
it can get really complicated so each
pattern that we saw before
will have a new color so if it's red
with a blue neighbor like red but the
blue neighbor is going to be this one
and this is now going to be pink and
this is going to be pink as well and so
on and so forth so if you wanted to wl2
you're going to look at patterns such as
like pink comma light green and that's
going to be like this one and this one
but not this one because this is a pink
with an orange as a neighbor
we do this to make sure we can do this
whole thing
efficiently computationally speaking
nonetheless you can try to understand in
an algorithm if you use the future
vectors as we have them before as 2 and
4 instead of the numbers that you get
from the kernels you could just do this
um this algorithm
with the vectors try to explain using
some models to explain which feature was
more important and then try to bring out
and say ah this particular graph was
deemed similar to
G1 or the whatever class because of that
pattern so you could try to explain
decisions as well using that but that's
another topic
an edge or relationship like is located
in so Bush house is located in London
you see how possible for any Behavior
because how could they they are
completely distracted by the computer of
all videos they're not even looking at
their own